hello hello there this is adam smith
from Nobel Prize org yet so we have a
tradition of interviewing new laureates
very briefly for the website could we
talk for just a few minutes who are be
my pleasure thank you very much indeed
well first of all sincere
congratulations oh thank you at a very
exciting day middle of the day it must
be in fact I've been talking since the
announcement with my old friend Richard
bond from Houston who's been oh you had
and he's loved Richard he's an old buddy
of mine indeed and he's been describing
that he's been hearing about the scenes
of jubilation that are going on in your
lab and that it's crammed with people
absolutely it's and it it's what when I
got in this morning which was a bit late
because I had been doing phone
interviews from home they had balloons
up they greeted me outside it's just
such a boost you know for the people in
the lab you know they work so hard every
day and you know to see recognition for
you know what we've been doing over the
years even if you know we've done you
know by their predecessors is is a huge
source of pride and excitement for all
of them it must be absolutely wonderful
I'm I guess its must have played havoc
with the plans for the day but that's
another story in fact I was supposed to
get a haircut at one o'clock today which
I badly need if you had video I'm sure
you would agree but instead I have a
news conference to do so the haircut
will have to wait a day or two but in
addition to the people on the lab
everybody you know putting the people
are just walking in a you know
colleagues and that have known me for
years and I sensed this tremendous sense
of institutional pride we've not had a
Nobel Prize at Duke we're a relatively
young institution at 75 years which
pales by comparison with things like
Javed or Princeton this kind of thing so
I think for everybody the institution I
think everybody is sort of feeling real
good about it and indeed there seems to
be a bit of a worldwide celebration
because your lab of course has been
working on GPCRs 44
decade and it's spawned an awful lot of
people who have gone out to other places
and the whole field seems to be happy
that there's an award now I think so and
I think you know as you probably know
better than than many the Nobel prizes
are often seen of course as awards to
individuals but beyond that their
recognition often of a field and so
everybody in the field feels good about
it especially if they feel good about
the particular people from the field who
are getting the award and you know I
read to think that you know the kind of
contributions that Brian and I have made
over the years uh generally you know
regarded you know very positively and as
being important in the field and so I
think everybody in the field I really
feels good about it those four decades
really have a been a sort of golden era
so discovery of neurotransmitter
receptors and absolutely and you know
the whole idea that there might be such
receptors goes back a century but you
know interestingly when I started doing
my work 40 years ago they were still
huge skepticism as to whether the
receptor whether things like receptors
really existed even from some of the
people who were central in pharmacology
and in the very early years of the work
there was a lot of pushback in terms of
well can you really do this you're
really isolating receptors how do we
know their receptors and now of course
it's you know to my students and fellows
that they're surprised to hear there was
ever such skepticism yes because I mean
your isolation and then sequencing of
the beta 2 adrenoceptor really well it
was the first isolation and it it sort
of gave the rosetta stone through which
everybody else was able to decode the
dozens of other I think terrific exactly
right and you know like so many
contributions incited it took years it
took us a decade to get these receptors
isolated and then another number of
years to get them cloned so we're
talking 15 years to get to that point
and similarly with co bill cos recent
crystal structures you can throw in
another 10-15 years there so I mean it's
tough it really is yeah it takes time it
takes perseverance exactly now it was
during the sequencing of the beater to
Audrina septa the project that that
Bronco Billy Joe
Joe lab and exactly he was a fellow
working in my laboratory we were
collaborating with a lab in at Merck and
we had already purified the receptor and
together with them we had gotten these
little stretches of protein sequence
which was truly the rosetta stone which
allowed the cloning the whole key to the
whole thing was that decade of work to
get the receptors purified and so
kobilka was sort of in my lab was the
fellow leading the the cloning work not
the original biochemistry and then we
were collaborating with a group at at
Merck but that was sort of his baptism
of fire so to speak and so he was very
active in that research and he was in my
lab really for about five years old
together and had a very productive time
it was clear to me then that he was a
very very special guy yeah what is it's
funny because he's disarmingly quiet
he's such a such a self-effacing chan oh
my goodness I think he's painfully shy
and yeah I think that's why he's very
self-effacing and that's just his
personality I think I think I hope he
can really enjoy this freshly today in
the next month or two because this is
not his comfort zone i would say exactly
when in fact we spoke to him earlier and
yes he was he was expressing the fact
that he probably thought he probably
wouldn't enjoy what was about to come
yes i think that correct yeah but but
hopefully he'll enjoy the trip to
Stockholm when well I hope you were I'm
hurry will but for the meantime we
should leave you to enjoy your
celebrations and unlike brand kobelco I
think you really sound like the sort of
person who would enjoy the next few days
I indeed I intend to enjoy this day to
the fullest I'll let you get on with it
then thank you very much to speak ok
thank you ok bye bye bye bye